i'm curious about something you've done
a lot of movie work uh but are you
mostly recognized as newman do most
people see you that way
yes i'm afraid but that's good you know
there's nothing wrong with it
um it's just that uh i'm now kind of
cornering the market on schleps and
weasels
i either play a a dumb slap or a nasty
weasel or
sometimes a nasty schlep or a dumb
weasel
it's your specialty but there's a perk
with this though i would think
you're becoming quite hot these films
you've been in a successful seinfeld of
course successful people
uh have a lot of fun with your character
you must get invited to really cool
celebrity events now
oh hell yeah all right
just the other night i was uh you know
they were opening that big warner
brothers store
uh you know and i'm in space jam so they
you know invited me over to
observe the merchandise which uh you
know there's a lot of
and um so you know they have the red
carpet and the paparazzi and they've got
like bleachers on the other side with
people going
ah you know to michael nobody uh did
that to me but
um just cricket noises when you came
past all right so uh
i go in there you know when we go down
the carpet people want the autograph
somewhere and we're all kind of
hobnobbing together and
sipping little beverages and having
little hot dogs or whatever
and there's patrick stewart and he's uh
from star trek the next generation
yes and of course other work and many
other things from
long ago and far beyond um so
i'm standing there with two of the
animators and he comes over we're
chatting and i'm feeling very
and he uh looks at me and says uh are
you one of the animators
and i said uh no i'm an actor oh really
and looked at me somewhat doubtfully i
said uh
no i'm on you know i'm i'm uh on
seinfeld a lot
he says that's odd that's my favorite
show
what and yet i don't recognize
oh god but still you got invited you got
to see the merchandise which is fine it
was a really nice stuff
yeah which you're not allowed to touch
yeah at space jam tell us about that uh
this thing is a
huge success was it was it fun uh fun
being in this movie
uh well you know it's kind of like being
in your room uh
i mean you're alone and uh and they're a
bunch of people wearing green stuff and
it's a big green stage
oh technically you mean they have to
kind of of course the animated stuff is
done later so you're acting to almost
you're acting to no one connecting to no
one yeah and
uh that's kind of nice
i've been in some uh you know did you
like uh did you like actually
you're working all these great athletes
in the movie too did you like doing that
well i was you know i did this one scene
where uh i look up and uh there's
michael and uh
patrick ewing and uh you know sean
bradley and larry johnson
and charles barkley and mugsy bogues and
i'm thinking uh
what is wrong with this picture
where's waldo you know i mean
[Laughter]
no i look like wayne of those little
yogurt raisins
you know i'm just kind of standing there
did you uh
did you i know that uh you know things
are going well for you now but when you
were first getting
started in your career you did some
broadway work which actually
you were working on a show where it was
it was a little tough to get people into
the seats wasn't well i mean i i did the
show uh gemini
um for three years so you know in the
beginning
it's a small house you're filling you're
filling the house and you're feeling
great and then as time goes on
it begins to thin out you know so uh
they were using uh
you see the bus and tunnel crowd come in
you know and people talk back to the uh
stage and uh people getting up to get a
drink in the middle of the act you know
uh
and uh one night we're doing the scene
where uh we're having
dinner we have this big scene where
everybody has the spaghetti dinner and
they serve out of this big spaghetti
bowl and
uh there's a woman in the front row and
she yells out uh
do you want a piece of cheese and uh
it's the oddest heckle i've ever heard
yeah it was kind of strange
and so we we kind of the first time you
just kind of get a little flinch and you
kind of take a light peek and you go on
uh
and she came down to the edge of the
stage with a
bag and said do you want a piece of
cheese
the guy playing the father looked at her
and he's giving her one of those get the
hell out of here lady looks you know
and she didn't kind of take to it and
said here
he have a piece of cheese and she
reaches in her bag grabs a piece of
cheese
and hurls it on the stage it lands in
the spaghetti bowl and the audience just
goes
wow you know they loved it they loved it
they thought it was like
part of the festival wrote this show has
been reworked beautifully we love the
cheese
live interaction with real cheese four
stars out of four
hey what the hell what the ding-dong
big piece of cheese
okay someone cheat through cheese
but uh the uh stage manager went out to
her you know after the uh
after the show or at the intermission
and said uh please you know leave the
actors alone don't interfere with them
she said
was i interfering he said yeah you know
i think throwing a piece of cheese on
stage
count that as minor interference
qualifies yeah she says i'm sorry
uh it turned out that um the first eight
rows of the house were uh supplied from
a mental hospital
uh oh my god um well it was you know it
was either that or one night you looked
out and it's just all sailors uniforms
so you get a kind of idea that
something's going on you know
a ship just pulled into town what do we
go see let's go see that broadway show i
hear they throw cheese around that's
right
it's great let me make sure i mention
this space jam is uh
of course out there theaters now
everywhere seinfeld like i need to plug
this but thursdays at nine
on nbc all right wayne thanks so much
for coming on thanksgiving
above and beyond the call of duty thank
you very much wayne night everybody
we'll take a break
we'll be right back